particle of mass five kilograms moves in
a circle of radius 4 meters on a smooth
horizontal surface okay now let me just
before we read the rest of the question
that word smooth smooth what that
indicates is there's no friction no
friction which is why I can tell oh it's
going to be uniform circular motion okay
there are other words that sort of like
that what you're seeing the question was
like why is that you'll see if there's a
for example of something moving along we
actually looked at this question
yesterday I think it's moving along a
horizontal surface attached to a stream
like so and they might say something
like the string is light and inelastic
okay why do you think they say what
what's the significance of that means
you're not contributing any mass because
it's light okay if I say it's in elastic
inelastic what that means it's it's
always going to retain that same lick
right so therefore it has a constant
radius so that's why it's circular okay
so those words aren't there for no
reason but for all intents and purposes
what they try to say is hey five
kilograms sweet horizontal surface
attached by a string to a point on the
surface what they want us to find is the
tension in the string T and you can't
say just tension you can use temperature
what could that be hits like these okay
yeah it said the clue is Newton's but
anyway that's okay what's the tension by
the way I will point out just like here
I tend to speak more in terms of forces
you don't have to call it tension
because maybe the force that's pulling
into the middle is in tension it might
be gravity whatever if I'm spitting at
that and then secondly and this by the
way I'm when we answer this question I
want to pull your mind back to what we
did yesterday on the basketball courts
there just just think about what is the
maximum number of revolutions per minute
if the stream will break when the if the
maximum tension is 8,000 meters okay so
that's the question that's the cell so I
am I kind of held your hand over here
how would you like
start this question just to enough
attention what what road should I get on
okay so I'm gonna have to be talking
about forces I'm gonna have to be xx
forces if I come back to over here right
forces over here what I'm really trying
to walk it work out is the normal force
that's equivalent attention in this
context to work out the normal force I'm
gonna need one two three things mass
radius and angular velocity I already
know mass and radius and angular
velocity is here really this question is
just the question of conversion right
this is revolutions per minute I don't
wanna let it go radians per second does
that make sense okay so I'm going to say
I'm just gonna deal with on with the
angular velocity first a velocity 180
revolutions per so that means every
second this is 60 seconds after all how
many revolutions are done doing three
I'm this is 60 second side to fire both
of my nodes by 60 that gives me three
revolutions per second it's pretty fast
I need this in radians now how many
radians is one revolution two pi so this
is six PI radians per second yeah don't
skimp on the units as you can see units
are everything in what I just did okay
all right
I just established that the forced
attention is gonna be depend on these
three things
so now I just need to substitute in the
normal force is gonna be negative five
times four times Omega squared yeah so
this is six yeah what's this this is 20
that's 36 that's negative 720 pi square
okay now because they have said tension
right that kind of takes care of the
fact that which direction is going in so
all I would do from this which tells me
more than what they're asking for is
I'll just tell them to mind you
the tension is 720 pi squared
Newton it's very good because it's a
force okay so far so good so what I had
to do here was work out what the tension
was based on all of these it's a
substitution okay now just have a look
at how this question is phrased and what
is it asking differently okay before we
knew mass radius and eventually we've
worked out their makeup okay here we
know what do we know now we still know
mass we still know radius but then they
provide for us this force and they're
trying to thank you
they're trying to work out what are we
trying to work out I'm trying to work
out angular velocity that's what I'm
after
okay this is just like a shifting around
the problem I'm still gonna write down
this right this is puppy I'm still gonna
write this as my starting point okay but
now I'm like here I'm just filling in
different things this force is going to
be now it's 8,000 Newtons but this
statement key includes the direction in
there so which way is it facing its
negative records facing towards the
center so I'm gonna write negative 8,000
this is already dr. unit taken off it so
and your shirt's is done I've got here
we already had that was five times four
right and then Omega squared that's the
under yeah so far so good
that's 20 so therefore Omega Square D
yeah so I'm going to take the square
root okay I'm just going to say this
because angular velocity whether you're
going clockwise or anti-clockwise is
immaterial to this question isn't it
it's just how fast can you go okay so
I'm just going to say let's just take
the positive value and you can define it
any way you like
the convention is that anti-clockwise
would be positive because we're like you
know if you well in radians yeah we're
like this right so you start from here
in the mirror upwards like that so it's
anti-clockwise there's a real way in
which the universe is energy clockwise
like you know right hand rule all that
kind of thing or if you think about that
the reason why we call clockwise
clockwise is because they don't know why
why why does the clock reading this so
it's connected to some dials and it's
also connected to the fact that we we
our script the English script is left to
right so it's like well if I start there
yeah so I don't know if Hebrew clocks go
the other way of it okay now I've worked
at Omega have I answered the question no
why not okay this is in radians per
second okay so what am I going to need
to do this to turn into minutes I'm
gonna have to do like if this is 20 in a
second then I'm gonna have to do in 60
seconds I'd do 60 of these right so
what's that
yes that's what 1,200 yeah
that's 1,200 radians per minute and then
I need to convert this into revolutions
so I divided by 2pi very good so um this
is going to be 1,200 on 2pi revolutions
per minute and of course you can cancel
s to be 600 apply